[Music]
hey today we're gonna talk about how to
build a custom entity extraction model
with Google Cloud auto ml natural
language if you've played with the
natural language API before you might
have seen that it can extract common
entities from text like the fact that
Google is an organization or that iPhone
is a consumer good but what if you want
to tag more domain specific entities
like types of diseases or the
specialized terminology you might find
in legal documents or patents for that
we'll use auto ml to train and build a
custom entity extraction model first
we'll need a labelled data set today
we'll build a model that analyzes
patents from Google's public patent data
set using Google visions OCR API we
extracted the text from a set of PDFs of
patents here we've stored that data in
adjacent L file which is the data type
that auto ml natural language expects
and we've manually tagged within that
text the character offsets of the custom
entities we want to extract Auto ml
natural language expects to read our
JSON L files from a Google Cloud bucket
in addition to our JSON L data we'll
make a CSV file that tells it where in
Google Cloud we've stored our data here
we specify which data files should be
used for training validation and testing
of our model if you don't break your
data set into these three files Auto Mel
natural language will do it for you
automatically
now let's upload our data here in the
auto ml natural language interface we'll
create a new data set to import the data
we give Auto ml natural language the CSV
file we made and then we wait importing
data can take a couple of minutes to
finish but you'll get an email and it's
done once our data is imported we can
view individual examples to make sure
they were labeled correctly we can check
where in the text different custom
entities were annotated we can also
annotate a new entity right here from
within the tool notice that we can also
tell how many examples we've got for
each label we can begin training a model
by navigating over to the trained tab
and clicking start training training a
model can take up to three hours behind
the scenes Auto ml will do a neural
architecture search to
the best model it can so now's a good
time to take a coffee break you'll get
an email when the models finished
training when training is finished we'll
be able to see our model here in the
training tab we can see how well it did
by clicking here to see full evaluation
here in the evaluate panel we can see
the performance of our model on
different labels the metrics we'll want
to look at our precision and recall
precision tells us of the snippets the
model labeled applicant how many were
really applicants recall tells us of all
the real applicants in our data set what
percent were accurately recognized by
the model we can also scroll down to see
where the model correctly labeled
applicant these are the true positives
and where it accidentally mislabeled
text as applicant or false positives in
the test and use tab we can start
actually using our model hosted by
Google to do that we first have to
deploy our model which could take a few
minutes next we can try to extract
custom entities on a new text snippet
there we go here are the custom entities
we extracted that's all for now
have fun modeling
[Music]